THE TOP YOU WANT, HERE.
GOOD PACE, AND A GOOD
BOUNCING PUCK AND A GREAT LOOK
HAYTON.
AND NOW HE'S CIRCLING OUT TYSON
ZAHORNA POKED LOOPING BY HAYTON
ACROSS THE BOARDS. NET FOR KELL
SENT AROUND, MAYO.
NI
PENGUINS.
>> Tyson: LET'S GO BACK TO THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
YOU TURN THE PUCK OVER THIS IS
WHWH
YES, IT IS
>> Tyson: ABSOLUTELY.
BEAUTIFUL BREAKAWAY SPEED THERE
PITTSBURGH SIDE?
THAT MAN RIGHT THERE.
>> Tyson: HE'S THE LEADER OF
POKING IT ALONG IS NICK RITCHIE
CROSBY.
PACK OUT THEM HERE TONIGHT.
MALKIN OFF THE NOBODY OF LONG.
35 PITTSBURGH SHOTS AND HE HAS
MADE 34 SAVES.
>> Tyson: SCOTT WEDGEWOOD AT TH
RETURNINGENTER
LANE DRIVE HERE.
THESE ARE THE DETAILS OF THE
IT DOWN LOW. N THE STAR
DENIED.
WHAT A RIDICULOUS
TOWARDS THE NET, AND IT IS
CROSBY AREA AND
SIDNEY CROSBY IS RIGHT THERE, H
SCORES A LOT OF
DUMOULIN FLIPS IT OUT.
NOW CROERE IS THE TWO ON ONE TH